are you buying these polls saying that
biden's going to be trump
let me tell you about where i live
where i live four years ago
there were signs in front of everybody's
houses
one way or the other more
trump for sure than there were for
clinton
you drive through my neighborhood today
you'd never know that election was
taking place
no signs anywhere nobody's saying
anything in private company
doesn't even come up as a subject
three political action committees with
republican money behind them
to elect biden
so i don't know what the silence means
i don't put much i don't put much in
polling
because the polls were completely wrong
and trump
rode into office showing us that the
polls
were wrong the polls were saying that
brexit wasn't going to happen and it did
so until they come up with a better
methodology for polling
i'm not going to put too much stock in
it but i can tell you
that the drive-by the way that warren
buffett used to assess
companies if i can kick him in the tires
and i can figure out what they are then
i'll buy him
fine i can't kick this election in the
tire
because nobody's saying what they're
doing i don't even see bumper stickers
nothing it's quiet
that tells me that biden will probably
win
but i don't know that tells you biden
will probably
win who are you more comfortable with
i don't know tell me who his vice
presidential candidate is going to be
okay which vice presidential candidate
would make you feel more comfortable
with him
i've always liked mike pence i'll tell
you that much
so i'm not going to answer your question
you just did
you just did well biden's not going to
choose trump i mean biden's not going to
choose pence
that's the point i i understand
look remember i'm sending two of my
bulls boys off to culver military
academy
which is on you know it's
half a mile from where pence's family
lives pence
pre trump i'm walking through the
indianapolis
airport i've been writing about unfunded
pensions for my entire career
and i'm walking through the indianapolis
airport which is a great airport by the
way
very clean and i'm reading this
billboard that says
our pension's the most funded in america
and i'm like
my hero who is this person so i stop i
google i stop boys google it
governor state of in indiana this is
june of 2016. i've never heard of mike
pence
what a way to look at it